Black holes are the largest collections of pure violent energy in the universe.
If you come too close,
they'll devalue and add your energy to that connection.
And so the energy is lost to us forever.
Or is as it turns out,
there's a universe cheat code,
a way of pairing civilizations until the very death of everything or of
constructing the largest bomb in the universe.
But how didn't we learn that all energy is trapped forever in black holes,
even light?
This is true.
Everything you think you know about the weirdest thing in the universe is about
to get weirder.
For one simple reason.
Black Holes are spinning.
Why?
Black holes spin
when ready,
ready?
Massive stars die there cause collapse under their own gravity into black holes.
This means something very big becomes very,
very tiny,
like the tiniest to anything can be in this universe.
But stars are rotating and they fundamental property of our universe is that
things that are spinning don't want to stop spinning.
We call this angular momentum and this angular momentum can't go away.
A big thing that spins and becomes smaller spins faster.
So as the core of a star collapses,
it's momentum,
makes it spin faster and faster and faster until it collapses into a black hole
and the bad cold keeps on spinning and conceivably fast.
Some of them spend millions of times a second.
Why spinning black holes are special,
just like non spinning black holes,
spinning black holes have an event horizon and a singularity at their core where
all of their mass is concentrated.
The singularity is usually described as a single infinitely small point with no
surface area,
but points can't rotate.
So a rotating singularity can't be a point.
Instead,
it's a ringing Darcy a ringing charity is a rank with a thickness of zero and no
surface spinning extremely fast containing all the mass of the black hole.
The black hole is spinning so fast that it morphs of space and time itself.
It literally drag space with us such as its power.
This creates a new and super weird region of space time.
The ergos fair,
which envelops the black hole.
If space and time are completely broken inside the event horizon,
then they're only half broken inside the Ergos Fair.
Inside the yogas fair,
nothing makes sense.
It's possible to enter it and then leave it again,
but it's probably not a great experience.
You can imagine it like this.
Falling into a static black hole is like a sliding down a hole being inside the
Ergos Fair of a spinning black hole.
It's like spiraling down a deadly drain.
The black hole transfers its own kinetic energy in the form of rotation to
everything that enters the ergos fair.
The ring you'd guarantee,
makes you dance.
Whether you want to or not,
you need to move faster than the speed of light's just to stand still here,
which is a possible,
but here's our cheat code.
We can steal.
There's energy and there's a lot of energy to steel
houses.
Steal Energy from a monster.
Take the supermassive black hole at the center of the Milky Way.
We could steal as much and as you from it as every single star in the milky way
or myths in a billion years combined.
The easiest way to steal this energy is of the enough to drop something into the
black hole.
We've seen that the ring in Iraqi forces energy on us when we enter the Ergos
fair,
which is a lot like being in a whirlpool with space time,
rushing around and around.
If you're clever,
you can use the water to your advantage and swim faster than before.
In practice,
this means sending a rocket into the other sphere and making a trade of the
black hole.
We give it some mass energy and it gives us some of its rotational energy,
but it's not a fair trade.
We get the better deal.
Normally if you fire a Rockies,
you exchange chemical energy for kinetic energy.
This is like pushing yourself forward in a swimming pool,
but if you fire a rocket inside the is fair,
it's like pushing yourself forward in a wave pool.
The rotational energy of the waves gives you a much stronger boost.
Then you could get just by pushing yourself.
The boost from the rotation of the black hole is so big that you leave the Ergos
fair with much more energy than you agitate.
The black hole gives a tiny amount of its rotational energy to you and slows
down a little.
Obviously this requires a lot of food for thought.
Only black holes aren't picky eaters and advanced future civilization would
probably harvest asteroids to drop them into the black hole when they needed an
energy boost,
but there's an even better way to get energy for a black hole and oddly enough,
it builds the biggest bomb.
Any living thing could ever hope to build the black hole bomb.
We only need two things to build a black hole bomb of fast spinning black hole
and a big mirror.
The mirror has to completely envelop the black hole,
which is similar to a Dyson sphere,
a mega structure that harvest the energy of an entire star,
although our mirror would be easier to build and there is a simpler and black
holes are much,
much more compact than stars.
If we made the merit 10 centimeters thick,
the metal of a big asteroid would probably be enough material for a black hole
with the mass of our sun.
Once our mirror is in place,
we only need to open a window and shoot electromagnetic waves of the black hole.
You can imagine what happens next by imagining tossing a ball at a wall and it
coming back faster than a Bullock's.
The waves hit the black hole.
At lightspeed,
a small proportion of the waves falls past the event horizon to disappear
forever,
but a much larger amount sloshes through the Ergos Fair where the black hole
forces some of its rotational energy on them and amplifies them.
They now begin super radiant scattering,
which aren't fancy science words,
meaning bouncing around between Mira and black hole and getting stronger every
time they go around.
They are getting exponentially stronger.
By opening some windows in the mirror.
We can extract the energy from the waves as fast as they grow,
which we could use in theory to create what would be for all practical purposes,
an endless source of energy for trillions of years.
Or we could blow it up.
If the waves are not released,
they will continue to get stronger and stronger and take more and more energy
from the black hole until the mirror shatters.
A supermassive black hole would release as much energy as a supernova making the
bomb,
the largest explosion any living being could ever create
the last home and a dying universe.
The beauty of the black hole bomb the Penrose process and the super radiant
scattering is that they are not science fiction in the far,
far future.
This might be the only way to survive in our dime universe.
After all the red dwarfs of cooled down and all the white dwarves transformed
into black doors,
the universe will turn dark forever.
Rotating black holes might be the only sources of energy in the entire universe
that's knife could harvest.
If so,
the last living being and existence might one day end its life around a black
hole,
which is equally chilling and uplifting.
It turns out that even without any light,
there are places we can go
black holes or as interesting as they are most areas,
but there's actually a surprising amount.
We do know using maths,
we can calculate things and come up with theories about how we die if we fall
into them.
If you're the sort of person who gets excited about maths and calculating these
things for yourself,
our friends at brilliant have put together a fantastic black hole quiz to help
you get your head around them.
Brilliant as a problem solving website that teaches you to think like a
scientist by guiding you through the problems they take.
Concepts like these,
break them up into bite size pieces,
present clear thinking in each part and then build back up to an interesting
conclusion.
If you visit brilliant.org/nacelle or click the link in the description,
you can sign up for free and learn all kinds of cool stuff and as a bonus for
courts,
Cozart view is the first 688 people will also get 20% off the annual membership.
If you want to truly learn about black holes and support codes cause aren't,
this is one of the best ways to do it.